hey guys I'm just McDonald it is the
30th of January and your children to
gamespot Daily News where the stories
are never more than 24 hours old usually
first up the xbox one is getting a
makeover sort of as originally posted on
NeoGAF and corroborated by the verge
Microsoft are working on a few
variations of the console which veer
away from classic black these variations
include a white one which already
existed and was made available to the
Xbox one dev team as well as several
which were auctioned off the charity if
it's what's on the outside that counts
for you then you may also be interested
in a linked image of an upcoming
titanfall themed Xbox one which in my
opinion doesn't look too bad if you're
more interested in the techie insides
then you may want to check out the
version with a one terabyte hard drive
or the machine that's being made without
a blu-ray drive let me know which one of
these variants you would pick up if you
could in the comments if you're big on
the rumor mill the neogaf thread in
question also featured a bunch of xbox
one tidbits including that halo 5 is
coming next year halo 2 will get an
anniversary edition full will see forza
horizon and sunset overdrive hit the
xbox one titanfall dlc is expected 45
days and then 120 days after release
crackdown 3 will be announced at e3 and
so many other details for the full list
which may indeed be completely unfounded
check out our story on gamespot for
die-hard mario kart fans it seems that
may is the time you'll have to hold out
for until the next installment Mario
Kart 8's release date was the first big
announcement from Nintendo's 2014
strategy briefing in Osaka yesterday
other points of interest include the
fact that a price cut for the Wii U
isn't an option that wii u gamepad is
the focus of the console and will not be
removed and that nintendo will be
licensing its characters to other
companies that doesn't mean that their
franchises will be headed for non
nintendo platforms anytime soon though
outside of all that Nintendo also want
to try out what they're calling non
wearables to monitor you
hell yeah I have no idea what that means
either let me know whether you think
this is a good 2014 strategy for
Nintendo and whether you reckon they're
going to crack on keeping their
franchises exclusive before we drop
Nintendo though it's worth letting you
know that for the next four days you can
get the legend of zelda four swords
anniversary edition on your 3ds or to do
so 3ds for free check out gamespot for
instructions as to how to get it right
now though I should warn you that it
seems to be a u.s. specific promotion
according to the disappointed Europeans
and Australians in the comments section
last of the mark I guess all that
publisher peace and love is out the
window since it seems today that
Microsoft is asking you to trade in your
old ps3 for a cheap xbox one should you
choose to part with your David cage and
naughty dog machine Microsoft have said
they'll give you one hundred dollar
store credit which would bring that xbox
one down to three hundred and
ninety-nine bucks ironically the same
price as the ps4 if you want to partake
in the offer all you have to do is drop
off your old console which still must
work I might add at a microsoft store
before march second the promotion will
also work with Xbox 360s and any models
if you like upgrading from a machine
with loads of games to one with not so
many do you guys think this will be a
popular promotion and will you be taking
Microsoft up on it you can let me know
either in the comment section down below
or on my Twitter where I'm at just
McDonald that's all the stuff I've got
for you today but be sure to join me
again tomorrow for my top five of the
week of the event
Oh